auch wenn das gute wetter im moment für
bessere stimmung sorgt corona müde sind
alle die durch fäden reisen öfter die
forderungen nach öffnungen zum beispiel
des einzelhandels die werden lauter
dazu wächst der ärger über versprochene
schnelltest und nicht verbrauchte
impfdosen die mutationen bereiten sorgen
so dass die politik keine hoffnungen
macht dass wir bald zur normalität
zurückkehren können
warnung vor der dritten welle lockern
oder nicht unser thema in der
frühlingssonne
phoenix runde
kroner gibt nicht einfach auf das wäre
es gibt nicht einfach aus aber wir haben
tag um tag mehr mittel mehr
möglichkeiten damit umzugehen und ein
stück normalität zurück zu gewinnen und
testen leistet dazu einen wichtigen
beitrag
das war bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
heute in der befragung der
bundesregierung herzlich willkommen aus
berlin zur phoenix runde ich darf ich
meine gäste vorstellen
ich begrüße professor dirk brockmann er
ist physiker und epidemiologe an der
humboldt universität in berlin und von
der anderen universität kommt professor
1000 phase er ist politikwissenschaftler
an der freien universität berlin
und mit unseren kollegen erhard scherfer
auch gastgeber des phönix podcasts unter
drei zugeschaltet ist uns heribert
prantl er ist kolumnist und autor der
süddeutschen zeitung schönen guten abend
herr brand
guten abend und das tel aviv ist und
zugeschaltet susanne glass leiterin des
ard-studios in israel dorthin schauen
wir allen einen schönen guten namen vor
glas guten haben dass israel
herr brockmann jetzt warnen alle vor der
dritten welle wir haben angst vor den
mutationen also es ist klar das virus
haben wir haben es noch nicht im griff
das virus hat uns im moment noch im
griff ist das zu viel
ja angstmacherei fast dass da noch was
kommen könnte dass man nicht denkt jetzt
haben wir endlich gegen geschafft also
angstmacherei ist es sicherlich nicht
das ist ja evident also wir können ja
uns die zahlen anschauen und diese neue
virusvariante oder eine dieser neuen
varianten die setzt sich durch die wird
halt stärker und nimmt mehr platz ein
und das hat man ja auch in dänemark zum
beispiel schon gesehen
in großbritannien irland das heißt und
alles was wissenschaftlich dafür spricht
dass die diese neue variante sich besser
übertragen lässt und das bedeutet das
natürlich auch dann eine gefahr
in einer dritten welle besteht selbst
wenn diese reproduktions zahl dieser
wichtigste zahl unter 1 ist kann es sein
dass im hintergrund hält diese virus
variante sich durchsetzt und dann
sozusagen das ruder übernimmt
das sind also varianten die tatsächlich
auch nicht so unwahrscheinlich sind also
wir müssen schon auch damit rechnen dass
das ein szenario ist was passieren kann
dass eine dritte welle kommt also wir
müssen damit rechnen oder sagen wir
haben auf jeden fall damit noch zu tun
und wir können nicht damit davon
ausgehen dass wir in ein paar monaten
ein normales leben weiterführen
na ja also wir haben ja verschiedene
methoden damit umzugehen also eine ganz
wichtige methode ist dass die inzidenz
runtergeht niedrige bereiche weil dann
die rückverfolgung besser funktioniert
dann kann man auch besser lockern
aber wir müssen auch diese lehre
produktion dieser neuen varianten so
weit runter drücken dass sie sich halt
nicht wieder exponentiell ausbreiten und
verschiedene sachen liegen ja jetzt auch
auf dem tisch wir müssen als schnell
impfen wir können tests nutzen also
verschiedene werkzeuge die wir zum
beispiel im letzten sommer noch gar
nicht hatten also auf der einen seite
hat das virus jetzt unsere neue variante
beschert aber wir haben auch neue
methoden damit umzugehen
herr prantl wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
so eine die dass die mutation uns halt
eben noch länger kein normales leben
wieder möglich machen
wie muss man damit umgehen die müdigkeit
ich habe schon angefangen der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat es auch
angesprochen alle sind pandemie müde ist
die müdigkeit erschöpfung kann das auch
ein argument sein dass man sagt ja wir
müssen jetzt lockern die möglichkeit
kommt nicht von ungefähr die möglichkeit
kommt daher dass nun die ganze krise und
die ganzen maßnahmen schon sehr sehr
lange dauern die müdigkeit kommt daher
dass der sogenannte lock down sehr
pauschal sehr generalisieren sehr wenig
differenzierend war und eine lockerung
des
das lockt bei uns ist ja nichts
unanständiges ist wieder darum zu fragen
wie viel normalität kann wieder
herrschen
und wenn sie eben herr brockmann sagt
die dritte welle und die gefahren sind
evident dann frage ich mich worauf
stützt sich die evidenz stützt sich die
auf die in steigenden infektionszahlen
auf die auch die sterbezahlen auf die
todeszahlen auf die art und weise wie
die intensivstationen überlastet sind
da hätte ich gerne von den epidemiologen
von den virologen deren expertise ich
schätze ein bisschen mehr an
kommunikation und ich denke die krise in
der wir uns jetzt befinden die müdigkeit
die das mürbe sein mit der krise hat
auch damit zu tun dass die kommunikation
von seiten dieser experten nach meinem
dafürhalten nicht sonderlich gut
funktioniert wenn die virologie wenn die
virologen sagen dass das dass das
rettende ufer ist nah dann haben die
leute das gefühl ich auch das rettende
ufer
wann wird immer wieder weiter weg sonst
macht die ganze sache etwas etwas
schwierig dann sie kurz dazu und dann
zur kommunikation heer fast daher
braucht man auch welche evidenzbasierten
sie das weil dieses mal herr brand lässt
direkt nach ja da gibt es natürlich
verschiedene verschiedene säulen auf
denen das steht will ich das mal so
sagen also eine ist ganz klar dass man
halt in anderen ländern beobachtet hat
wie schnell diese neue virusvariante
sich durchsetzt aus dieser aus diesen
kurven kann man dann schätzen wie viel
wahrscheinlicher eine übertragung mit
dieser neuen variante ist das kann man
in dänemark angucken in irland aber auch
irgendwo anders auf der welt kann man
das dann schätzen und dann ist man ja
zum beispiel über die fallzahlen diese
diesen erwert und wir wissen dass der
etwa zwischen jetzt so die letzten
wochen zwischen 0,8 und 0,9 geschwankt
ist aber das wird dominiert durch diesen
will typ der sich überall schon
ausgebreitet hat und wenn sich innerhalb
dieser gruppe dann diese neue variante
ausbreitet dann ist die
die produktion dieser variante größer
als 1 und man muss aber auch
gleichzeitig immer berücksichtigen in
den modellen zum beispiel die michael
herrmann entwickelt aber auch andere
gruppen die ja sozusagen die die
prognostischen arbeiten dann machen dass
das immer kombiniert sein wird mit zum
beispiel dass wir sozusagen
unkontrolliert lockern das heißt alles
was also lockern die frage woran lassen
wir uns messen
wir sind wir haben immer gesagt werden
die krankenhäuser nicht überlasten
die gesundheitsämter nicht so lang ist
wie aber das ist ja weg gebracht ich das
ja das hat er erst mal gar nichts damit
zu tun sondern wie sich das virus
ausbreitet hat einfach was mit
übertragung zwischen er tun also in und
dem versuchen wird so niedrig wie
möglich zu halten genau genau brandl
sprache kommen die kommunikation der
wissenschaft an ich würde gerne mit
ihnen mehrfach über die kommunikation
der politik sprechen
der bundesgesundheitsminister musste
sich heute im bundestag den fragen der
abgeordneten stellen erwies sich auch
viel um die schnellste ja versprochen
hatte zum ersten märz
und überhaupt über das grundsätzliche
krisen-management wie hat er sich
geschlagen
naja wenn man bedenkt wie schwierig die
letzten tage doch für ihn waren er wurde
zurückgepfiffen bei dieser schnelltest
strategie dann ist ja da eigentlich sehr
offensiv und gerade zu forsch
aufgetreten
aber das passt natürlich auch zu ihm er
ist ein kommunikationsprofi durchaus das
haben wir in vielen phasen erlebt aber
im moment geht es ja glaube ich eher
darum bestimmte dinge auf die straße zu
bringen sprichwörtlich und das ist
glaube ich das schwierige mit aus
kommunikativer sicht in diesen tagen was
man die leute mitnehmen muss dass man
klarmachen muss das ist eine kritische
phase ist und es ist weniger die
tatsache dass die menschen glaube ich
die maßnahmen nicht akzeptieren
natürlich gibt solche die sagen
die maßnahmen müssen gelockert werden
aber wenn sie sich um fragen an kommen
und gucken wir haben diese zero cobit
debatte ist genauso viele leute die
sagen
eigentlich müssten die maßnahmen noch
viel weiter gehen das gefährliche gerade
ist dass das vertrauen eigentlich
schwinde das vertrauen in die
managementfähigkeiten ich habe wenn wir
einmal gewählt hat versprochen die sind
nicht diese kämpften warten so zu sagen
aber wenn man minister zurück dann hat
dann haben wir jede menge also millionen
unverbrauchte dosen impfstoff von
astrazeneca also das ist doch wo sind
die positiven nachrichten aber das ist
glaube ich genau der punkt wenn wir
dieses jahr was wir jetzt mit der
pandemie erlebt haben revue passieren
lassen dann ist es ja eine unglaubliche
komplexität die für jemand der kein
epidemiologe oder virologe oder
virologen es eigentlich kaum zu
durchdringen ist insofern ist der faktor
vertrauen wirklich ganz ganz wichtig und
gerade dieser faktor das vertrauen in
die regierung ich meine man sich umfang
anguckt dann ist dieses vertrauen in
deutschland wahnsinnig hoch gewesen
und durch dieses missmanagement und auch
die wahrnehmung des missmanagements
schnelltest impfung ist gerade dieses
vertrauen glaube ich im moment gefährdet
und das ist das was mir so ein wenig
sorge genau aus dieser kommunikativen
sicht gerade bereitet
und dann schauen alle nach israel und
sagen schaut doch mal in israel da geht
das alles viel besser da wird viel
schneller geimpft und da haben die
menschen eigentlich fast wieder normales
leben frau glas in tel aviv ist das so
in israel kann man sagen ja weil sie
persönlich sind geimpft haben sie wieder
ein fast normales leben im moment nein
bei weitem nicht ich habe absolut kein
normales leben im moment und für nicht
vielleicht bevor ich die frage
beantwortete kurz sagen darf wir sind in
israel ja nicht nur bei den impfungen
voraus wir sind auch im prinzip was
lockt downs und wellen betrifft voraus
wir hatten die dritte welle schon und es
hat sich gezeigt dass der lockdown
eigentlich nicht unbedingt einfluss auf
die zahl der infizierten hatte ich denke
das hat sich hier dann erst wieder
leicht gebessert mit den impfungen ich
persönlich wenn sie mich fragen also ich
musste mich zusammenreißen dass ich der
erste nicht um den hals gefallen bin als
ich die impfung bekommen habe und ich
hab manchmal schon das gefühl dass ich
hier mehr oder weniger in einer
parallelwelt lebe wenn ich dann
mitbekomme wie verzweifelt meine
bekannten in deutschland versuchen für
ihre betagten eltern einen impftermin zu
bekommen und bei mir in tel aviv an
mittlerweile die lkws mit großen
lautsprechern durch die straßen die die
jungen leute auffordern zur impfung zu
gehen und ihnen ein freigetränk in der
bar versprechen oder auch humus oder
gratis pizza also das sieht man schon
dass das welten dazwischen sind auf der
anderen seite wir haben den grünen passt
darüber wurde viel berichtet mit dem
grünen passt kann ich im moment in ein
fitnessstudio gehen den bekommen alle
die geimpft worden sind oder die
chinesen sind ich kann mittlerweile auch
wieder in eine shopping mall zum
einkaufen gehen dazu braucht es
überhaupt keinen grünen passt aber der
flughafen ist nach wie vor geschlossen
wir haben jetzt die buam feiertage da
gibt es wieder eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre ist es noch nicht sicher
ob man hier nicht doch wieder zu einem
locker und greifen muss denn es zeigt
sich halt mehr und mehr dass sich 30
prozent der bevölkerung nicht impfen
lassen möchte vor allem junge wollen
sich nicht impfen lassen auch sehr viele
streng religiöse juden oder auch
arabische israelis und das wird hier
mehr und mehr zu für eine zu einem
problem von der tann ja auch gerade eben
hatte übrigens eine pressekonferenz
abgehalten hat noch einmal aufgefordert
geht zum impfen in der ganzen welt
warten die leute auf den impfstoff und
in israel wartet der impfstoff auf die
menschen die kommen also dass es im
moment so die situation
ok brannte wenn sie das hören aus israel
dass es nicht genug impfwillige gibt
obwohl es genug impfstoff gibt und dass
man mit diesem grünen passt sich wieder
etwas freiheiten erkaufen kann sozusagen
durch die impfung ist das was sie sagen
das würde ich mir für deutschland auch
wünschen ich will mir für deutschland
wünschen dass es genügend impfstoff gibt
dass die möglichkeit gibt dass die leute
schnell zum impfung kommen
die situation hier ist eine katastrophe
und planungsausschuss eine katastrophe
ist die nicht existenz des impfstoffs
die art und weise wie der impfstoff
nicht zur verfügung steht die auch die
ganze beschaffungs die
beschaffungsmaßnahmen des impfstoffs die
frage wie der impfstoff hier mangelware
ist die leute wollen wir impft werden
die warten darauf und aber es geht an
bord von sparen ist
ihr werdet vielleicht wäre es vielleicht
im september im oktober im november
geimpft
das ist eine katastrophe und wenn sie
wenn es jemals wenn jemals ein
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag
notwendig war dann ist er in dieser
frage notwendig was ist da
schiefgelaufen
warum wurde zu wenig eingekauft was ist
hier auf europäischer ebene passiert da
sind dinge schiefgelaufen die ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann und die ich gern im
bundestag geklärte und die geklärt
werden müssen aber 100 aber der
situation wie sie israel besteht aber es
gibt im moment ja zuviel impfdosen von
astrazeneca der geimpft werden soll bis
64 da bleiben das sind 1,4 millionen
ausgelieferten oder 211.000 sind
verimpft also das wie erklären sie das
denn ich bin kein mediziner werden die
leute sagen
der impfstoff ist nicht derjenige der
mir den ich haben will dann wird man das
akzeptieren müssen
und es ist ja so dass die leute warten
aber sie wollen auch vertrauen haben
dass der impfstoff der ihnen gespritzt
wird dass der funktioniert dass sie
nicht davor angst haben müssen
und da ist viel auch kommunikativ falsch
gemacht worden
die biologen sorgen dieser impfstoff ist
ideal
dann frage ich möchte warum ist es nicht
ausreichend kommuniziert worden und dann
einmal direkt fragen wenn man fragen wir
den wissenschaftler
er braucht man wie gut ist der astra
zeneca ist eben stoff um das einfach mal
vielleicht zu klären also eher brandl
hatte ja anfangs was von kommunikation
oft man sich auf kommunikation bezogen
und jetzt in diesem ganzen kontext ist
das absolut richtig weil viel besser
kommuniziert werden muss wie gut dieser
astrazeneca impfstoff ist im vergleich
zu den m rna impfstoffen die ja extrem
gut oder besonders geeignet sind für die
risiko bevölkerung also die älteren
menschen und was halt auch kommuniziert
werden muss und das ist auch das problem
natürlich ist es klar dass wenn wenn ich
mir das aussuchen kann das zeigen auch
die cosmo studien von
cornelia betsch aus erfurt wenn ich mir
das aussuchen kann dann nehme ich
natürlich ein impfstoff der auf dem
papier besser läuft aber es gibt auch
ganz viele menschen die gerne diesen
impfstoff hätten weil sie dann geimpft
sind weil er ja auch schon sehr sehr
wirksam ist
die kommen aber noch nicht dran und es
gibt ja sozusagen eine priorisierung und
da muss man halt überlegen also das
zeigen zum beispiel modellrechnung die
wir gemacht haben dass es ein riesen
unterschied macht wenn wir astrazeneca
die jetzt die nächsten wochen und dann
insbesondere im ersten
in der ersten hälfte des zweiten
quartals haben wir da substanziell viel
impfen können also richtig dampf machen
dann kann man am ende des zweiten
quartals also anfang juli schon viel
besser da stehen also alles was jetzt da
ist müsste so schnell so schnell wie die
romandie leute die es haben wo er da
gibt es einen vorschlag hier aus berlin
die sozialsenatorin der spd elke
breitenbach sagt jetzt wir wollen die
nicht liegen lassen
wir geben das jetzt obdachlosen ist das
jetzt der richtige das richtige signal
ja also man muss zwei glaube ich zwei
spuren fahren es gibt eine priorisierung
die die stiko ausgearbeitet hat und die
ist genau die ständige impfkommission
ausgearbeitet hat und dies auch sehr
stark optimiert wenn es da aber in
diesem system zu einem stau kommt und
dass andere leute gibt gerade in der
jungen bevölkerung die geimpft werden
wollen die astrazeneca nehmen würden und
damit ja sozusagen zu herdenimmunität
beitragen dann ist das auch ein weg dann
spricht nichts dagegen
zwei stränge zu fahren das muss
natürlich klar weil man nicht gemacht
werden ist es entscheidend bei der
ganzen kommunikation gerade mit diesen
impfstoffen was läuft da schief wie
könnte man das besser man wer müsste es
ändern
na ja auch an der stelle sieht man
glaube ich dass es ganz verschiedene
erklärungen gibt und die kolleginnen
kollegen von herrn brantl haben wir
recherchiert dass es eben eigentlich
auch an der stelle management problem
ist dass im moment eben der impfstoff
nur an diese prioritäten gruppe 1
verteilt werden darf die sind aber
inzwischen fast alle gm
und irgendwie scheint man das versäumt
zu haben jetzt einfach für weitere
abnehmerin abnehmer zu sagen also ist
ein kleines fragezeichen daran uns
wirklich die mangelnde impfbereitschaft
auf seiten der menschen ist ob die
wirklich alle gerne bei montech hätten
oder ob es an der stelle auf
management problems gefährlich ist
glaube ich so wichtig dass es so herr
branche hat eben das schärfste schwert
sozusagen für den untersuchungsausschuss
natürlich sind diese fragen wer ist
wofür verantwortlich extrem wichtig nur
durch solche debatten ist es in der eu
probleme es ist ein wissenschaftler
problem ist es ein cdu spd problem damit
erzeugt man glaube ich viel zynismus
weil dann der eindruck entsteht es geht
hier eigentlich nur um seine schuld
management wer hat denn am meisten
verbraucht aber die menschen wollen
natürlich geimpft werden insofern ist
glaube ich auch diese debatte alleine
gefährlich weil sie ebenso ein sehr
zynisches bild auf das ganze wirft oder
ein licht auf das die situation wird und
wir die sache dabei so ein bisschen in
auf die zweite ebene verschieben hier
brannte untersuchungsausschuss das wäre
der blick zurück dann würde man ja sagen
wer hat wann welche verantwortung gehabt
oder bzw
nicht übernommen was würden sie denn
jetzt ich will sagen sie denn wer müsste
denn jetzt wirklich ja das management
verändern
natürlich muss sparen das management
veränderte sparen muss werben ersparen
muss ja kommunikativ tätig werden das
würde gerade gesagt von einem vater ist
ein großer kommunikator muss nicht nur
ein info angebot machen hat ja vor
einiger zeit gesagt bis zum sommer wird
jeder impfangebot kriegen einen
unvollständigen wenn es wenn das
infoangebot heißt was die leute im
august ein angebot kriegen und dann im
november und dezember zum impfen dran
kommen dann ist das wort angebot fast
ein betrügerisches wort baukelmann den
leuten eine schnelle impfung vor die es
nicht gibt es würde gerade etwas
umgangssprachlich gesagt es muss land
gemacht werden
dieser dampf muss mit allen mitteln
passieren es muss eigentlich und das ist
glaube ich die einzige möglichkeit die
ich sehe um die krise zu bewältigen es
muss bis
sommer so gut es nur geht und so vieles
neu aufteilen und da müssen muss der
bundesgesundheitsminister gefordert sein
und da müssen die länder
gesundheitsminister gefordert sein da
muss ein großes zusammen zusammenwirken
passieren und meisten fehlt das
vertrauen muss wiederhergestellt würden
aber dass der gesundheitsminister hat
heute auch bei der befragung immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen dass die
länder zuständig sind da kommen wir
immer wieder in dasselbe in dasselbe
problem dieses ping pong muss in dieser
situation aufhören natürlich sind wir
ein föderales system aber föderale
system heißt ja nicht dass jeder die
verantwortung dem anderen zuschiebt
föderale system heißt letztendlich dass
die entscheidungen so nah an den
problemen getroffen werden sollen wie es
nur geht und wir sehen in corona ist ein
kabinett oder einen konvent von
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin
tätig so ähnlich muss es doch auch mit
den gesundheitsministern funktionierende
müssen sich in den konferenzen
zusammenschalten und müssen schauen zu
impfungen kommen und neues vertrauen
schaffen ja frau glas ist es in israel
gelaufen wie was ist gut gelaufen
kommunikativ gibt es was wo man sagt da
können wir auch was von lernen weil es
gibt natürlich weil es ist ja
interessant zu sehen dass gerade die
jungen leute auf einmal sich nicht mehr
impfen lassen wollen
ja das stimmt das aber die jungen leute
die haben eben auch schon sehr viel
erfahrung und haben gesagt gerade bei
der jüngeren generation sind die meisten
fälle gar nicht so schlimm verlaufen wir
fürchten uns er vor den folgen der
impfung als vor den folgen einer
infektion das ist das eine auf der
anderen seite kann natürlich israel
jetzt auch nicht immer als beispielland
für deutschland vorgenommen werden
israelis wie klein wir haben 9,3
millionen einwohner ist ein zentral
regiertes land aber da sieht man eben
denke ich ganz klar auch was in
deutschland versandt wurde stichwort
digitalisierung in israel sind alle in
vier großen krankenkassen digital
erfasst da geht das ratzfatz und was ich
auch ganz spannend finde ist am anfang
hat man in israel gesagt die über
60-jährigen werden geimpft und jeden
abend in tel aviv haben sich
junge leute angestellt am abend und
haben gesagt wenn diejenigen die den
impfstoff bekommen dürfen wenn die durch
sind und es ist noch was übrig dann
hätte ich das gerne und das wurde
anstandslos verimpft da gab es auch
überhaupt keine diskussion darüber dann
verfolge ich die diskussion in
deutschland möchte nicht falsch
verstanden werden ich finde es toll wenn
man ethische herangehensweisen hat aber
wenn ich dann mitbekomme wie ich selber
verzweifelt in der telefon hotline in
baden württemberg für meine mutter hier
und was da slapstick artige szenen sich
abgespielt haben weil nichts
funktioniert hat da denke ich mir und
jetzt diskutierte darüber wer die wette
wer die ansonsten dosen bekommt die
weggeworfen werden also das fand ich
dann schon ein bisschen heftig das denke
ich immer braucht hier pragmatische
zugänge und die gibt es in israel
jetzt habe vielleicht noch einen satz
zum datenschutz und da muss man sich
eben auch schon sehr klar sein israel
hat die daten an pfizer verkauft das war
grundlage des deals warum man diesen
vielen impfstoff so rasch bekommen hat
und jetzt gibt es hier große
diskussionen gerade heute hat auch die
knesset zugelassen dass alle daten von
denen die sich nicht geimpft haben an
die gemeinden gegeben werden das heißt
die schulen wissen jetzt welcher lehrer
sich nicht impfen lassen wollte welche
jugendlichen über 16 nicht geimpft sind
das wissen dann auch die firmen was man
damit macht weiß man noch nicht aber das
ist die kehrseite der medaille des
erfolges
herr was denken sie das könnte man in
deutschland durchsetzen weil auf der ein
teil dieser schaut man nach israel aber
das ist ja die die kehrseite wehrmann
bereit das mitzunehmen
nein das glaube ich nicht wenn wir an
die debatte denken die wir um die app
hatten die kommune app dann merkt man
einfach dass wir in deutschland sehr
sensibel sind an diesem punkt zwischen
datenschutz auf der einen seite
gesundheitsschutz auf der anderen seite
und es geht ja nicht nur um diesen
beiden zielkonflikte wir reden über die
die jungen menschen die kinder die nicht
in die kitas dürfen wir reden über die
wirtschaft da geht es einfach um ganz
fundamentale priorisierung wie man so
oder so abwägen kann wir haben glaube
ich bisher ein jahr erlebt wo ganz klar
der schutz von leben von schutz vor
krankheiten vieles dominiert hat das
verschiebt sich jetzt so ganz allmählich
eben auch durch diese müdigkeit die sie
angesprochen haben
aber es bleibt natürlich so dass es um
ganz fundamentale fragen geht
grundrechtseingriffe massivste art die
dadurch auch diesen lockt am permanent
und völlig zurecht auch in frage stellen
und dazu kommt ich finde auch das merkt
man sich ein wenig wenn er über
kommunikation denken wäre ein super
wahljahr und man merkt schon dass auch
das bemühen sozusagen parteipolitisch
den einen oder anderen akzent zu setzen
jetzt doch mehr und mehr sichtbar wird
das ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht
denn auch das gehört zu einer demokratie
aber es macht sozusagen so den faktor
vertrauen eine einheitliche linie die
wir manchen situationen umgehen nicht
unbedingt einfach herr prantl was denken
sie wenn sie das hören wir in israel mit
daten umgegangen wird wäre das was sie
sagen okay wenn wir dann dadurch ein
freieres leben bekommen wäre ich auch
bereit das so mitzutragen
das ist die ultimative ja ich meine wir
grundrechte weg gott lieben wir
grundrechte auf wenn wir dadurch
möglicherweise die möglichkeit besteht
ein bisschen weiter in der
krisenbekämpfung voranzukommen wir haben
im vergangenen jahr grundrechtseingriffe
gehabt wie wir sie in der geschichte
dieser republik noch nicht erlebt haben
die tiefgreifendsten die
weitreichendsten und ich bin wirklich
froh und dankbar sein nämlich eine
kleine grundrechts debatte beginnt die
grundrechte schienen lange zeit aus der
ganzen betrachtungsweise völlig
weggeschoben zu sein und man muss
wirklich etwas pathetisch sagen der
freiheitliche verfassungsstaat ist nicht
per se und überzeitlich gesichert man
muss auch dem corona management grenzen
gezogen werden das heißt nicht dass ich
für ein niedriges krisen-management
werbe aber auch in krisen management
muss grundrechte achten die grundrechte
heißen grundrechte weil sie auch in
katastrophen seiten gelten
und ich denke sie sind die wegweiser für
unsere gesellschaft wie wir auch in
krisenzeiten mit so einer krise umgehen
wir müssen sehen wir haben wir können
sie können sämtliche artikel durchgehend
von artikel 1 bis hin zur berufsfreiheit
zur gewerbefreiheit alle sind massiv
tangiert worden die existenzen von
zehntausenden von 100.000 menschen sind
gefährdet
die bewegungsfreiheit ist so
eingeschränkt wie noch nie
natürlich ist es richtig dass das
grundrecht auf leben geschützt werden
muss aber wir müssen abwägen mit anderen
grundrechten wir müssen und
verhältnismäßigkeit unterhalten
das wird glaube ich die diskussion der
nächsten wochen und der nächsten monate
sein und diese diskussion ist richtig
und jetzt wieder zu sagen datenschutz
weg dann funktioniert die ganze corona
bekämpfung besser es ist der falsche
argumentation das ist ja auch keine hopp
oder topp diskussion das heißt ja nicht
digitalisierung dann muss man den
datenschutz aufgeben sondern es gibt ja
lösungen
der datenschutz ist ja da und dann muss
man lösungen entwickeln wie das vieh
dinge datenschutzkonform gemacht werden
können ohne dass man gar nicht auf
digitale methoden setzt zum beispiel das
war zum beispiel bei der korona vanek
jahrelange debatte macht man das zentral
oder dezentral wir gar nicht darauf
eingehen ob die funktioniert und so
weiter aber das hat ja war eine lange
debatte was mich in der in der
diskussion so ein bisschen stört ist das
revier nehmen zb israel und und
überlegen kann das so zu sagen so eine
schablone sein
aber das bedeutet ja nicht dass man
alles übersetzen muss direkt oder
großbritanniens anderes gutes beispiel
oder die usa die mit einer hohen quote
mittlerweile gehen sondern es geht
eigentlich darum und das ist das lerne
ich aus den berichten aus israel dass
das man besser mit ausnahme situation
klarkommt also hier habe ich oftmals das
gefühl dass wir routine prozesse
versuchen auf eine ausnahme situation
anzuwenden also was wir aus einem sehr
effizienten routinebetrieb kennen dass
wir das anwenden wollen und das geht
schief weil es viel zu langsam ist hat
etwas damit zu tun dass israel auch ganz
andere krisen gewöhnt ist ja und dass
sie halt genau das ist viel dass sie
viel dynamischere die die pandemie ist
erstens neu sie ist hoch dynamisch und
sie ist in vielen dingen unverstanden
und das heißt wir müssen mit mit
fragmentierten wissen umgehen ja wir
müssen wir können nicht drei jahre
warten bis wir die evidenz haben wir
müssen jetzt entscheiden
öffentlich den friseur in den baumarkt
genau wir müssen jetzt das ist halt das
kriegt nämlich mit routine aber das
kriegt man nicht mit den etablierten
prozessen hin
da sehe ich immer den frau glas was ist
denn so ihr eindruck ist es auch eine
andere eine andere haltung klar wir
können das nicht eins zu eins
vergleichen aber gibt es was wo man sagt
ja da gibt es vielleicht eine andere
andere krisen erfahrungen die das dann
auch wodurch man halt eben bestimmte
dinge einfach oder bestimmte situationen
besser händeln kann sich also es liegt
sicherlich daran sie uns vorher selbst
schon angesprochen israel ist viele
krisen gewöhnt und man nimmt dann auch
vieles hin also stichwort datenschutz
ich habe da schon oft sehr geschluckt
und wenn ich das mit meinen israelischen
bekannten angesprochen habe dann um die
gesagt na ja wieso wir sind doch ohnehin
was das handy betrifft längst alle
geprägt und das ist jetzt nicht so
tragisch interessant wird's was ich
angesprochen habe jetzt gerade die
debatte was passiert mit denen die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen und ich denke
das wird hier auch noch das höchste
gericht gehen da ist das letzte wort
hier absolut nicht gesprochen
ok ich würde auch gern einmal den
bundesgesundheitsminister zu wort kommen
lassen weil er also wenn man ihnen heute
gehört hat hat man nicht den eindruck
dass wir schnell lockern werden
stichwort mutationen spannende frage ist
was macht das unter bedingungen von
mutation und höhere ansteckungsfähigkeit
in anderen bereichen
und ich werde jedenfalls dafür als
bundesminister für gesundheit sie können
das anders sehen
ich wäre sehr dafür dass wir diese
schritte vorsichtig gehen weil nichts
wäre fataler übrigens auch für die
akzeptanz wenn wir in vier oder sechs
wochen wieder vor ganz anderen stellen
in vier oder sechs wochen haben wir auch
schon landtagswahlen hinter uns herr
farce und es gibt wenn es um die
akzeptanz geht wie wichtig ist es dass
man jetzt sagt ja wir müssen jetzt
lockern oder was was zahlt ein auf
vertrauen und auf akzeptanz woran lässt
sich das messen also vertrauen das erst
mal wollte ich ganz ganz wichtig weil es
extrem komplexes und wir alle glaube ich
nicht wir schauen worum es im detail
geht wir müssen darauf vertrauen können
dass die richtigen entscheidungen
getroffen werden und ich glaube dass es
bisher auch grundsätzlich passiert aber
jetzt steuern wir schon länger die
zahlen gehen schon länger zurück
irgendwie erwarten jetzt doch alle dass
die situation sich entspannt
und wenn jetzt aber an diese situation
diese bei 117 variante tatsächlich
dominant wird und uns wirklich zurück
wirft muss sich nur auf das vertrauen
was was sie ihr und ihren kolleginnen
kollegen sagen aber das ist ja durchaus
besorgniserregend
dann hat jens spahn glaube ich an der
stelle schon ein punkt jetzt zu öffnen
und dann in vier wochen noch mal zu
sagen stopp wir müssen zurück zu dem was
wir vorher hatten vielleicht noch
massiver das für dieses hin und her das
ist glaube ich wirklich schwierig man
lasse an dieser woche davon in nürnberg
waren einen tag die schulen auf dann
musste man sich wieder schließen weil
die inzidenz plötzlich wieder über 100
lag also ich glaube solche
schnellschüsse ist irgendwie schließen
oder öffnen und das ist so wenig
klugheit
naja so sieht es eben sehr schnell aus
weil man auch die begründungen eben
nicht immer transparent macht weil die
sich auch ändern im laufe der zeit ganz
lange hieß es immer die nachverfolgung
50 ist so eine grenze dass können die
gesundheitsämter schaffen
diese zahl an neuinfektionen können sie
nachverfolgen
jetzt steht diese 35 im raum ich glaube
dies nicht neu erfunden worden was was
armin laschet einmal etwas unglücklich
formulierte aber trotzdem plötzlich ist
es eine andere begründung und die ist
dann plötzlich da und dann nimmt man die
leute glaube ich nicht immer mit in dem
das man plötzlich ist der rahmen ein
ganz anderer und das argument dass wir
über viele monate wochen jetzt gemacht
haben das gilt so einfach plötzlich
nicht mehr wissenschaftlich ist das
glaube ich nicht umstritten unbedingt
aber man braucht eben die akzeptanz in
der bevölkerung und wer weiß im ernst
was ein r wert ist weil es seine sieben
tage incidents ist das ist glaube ich
das spannungsverhältnis indem wir uns
hier bewegen java herbrand land was
sollte sich die politik da also
hauptsächlich orientieren oder messen
lassen ist es wirklich ist es die zahl
der infektionen ist es die zahl der der
toten ist es die zahl der
wirtschaftlichen pleiten also wenn sie
jetzt in dieser politischen entscheidung
situation und nach was würden sie sich
den richten
das ist auch keine isolierte zahl es
geht doch darum all diese dinge die sie
jetzt aufzählen die sie andeuten
in die überlegungen mit einzubeziehen
ich muss mir ja erst mal überlegen was
schütze ich denn eigentlich geht es mir
um die individuelle gesundheit bei den
einzelnen maßnahmen die ich treffe bei
den ausgangssperren bei den
beherbergungsbetrieben
geschäftsschließungen oder geht es mir
um die volksgesundheit um die
öffentliche gesundheit also um die art
und weise wie die krankenhäuser die
krisen bewältigen
die einzelnen maßnahmen sind ja auch von
den zielen die ich mir stelle abhängig
und jetzt würde ich wirklich sehr sehr
differenzieren
ich würde bei den schulen ganz klar bei
der öffnung der schulen bleiben ich
würde bei der eröffnung der museen
bleiben
ich würde vorsichtig überlegen ob man
die sportstätten wieder öffnen kann die
leute werden ja irgendwann wahnsinnig
wenn sie sich nicht mehr betätigen
können was redet zu recht vom vertrauen
ich muss bei aller vorsicht die herr
sparen angemahnt bei der eröffnung bei
der lockerung versuchen
dahin zu kommen dass das vertrauen der
bevölkerung wieder da ist wir müssen bei
all dem auch sehen wir leben in einem
ganz großen war ja wir haben eine fülle
von wahlen vor uns bis zur
bundestagswahl im september
demokratie lebt von der überwindung
sozialer distanz bei der pandemie
bekämpfung haben wir immer wieder gesagt
es geht darum die soziale distanz
irgendwie so gut es geht
herzustellen so viel soziale distanz
herzustellen wie es nur geht ich frage
mich immer beschaulichen beuck kampf in
diesem zeichen aus
dabei kam es besteht aus versammlungen
der wahlkampf besteht aus aus daraus
dass die politiker an der haustür
klingeln gegen das die mit leuten reden
wie sollte es anders ausschauen ja wo
die cdu auch alkohol jetzt dann gewählt
eine ganz andere art aber die frage ist
ja jetzt haben wir ja ein jahr fast fand
die witwe übertrage sich das auf das
große kann ein parteitag mit 1000 mit
2000 leuten noch die wahl abhalten kann
ich dann einen bundestagswahlkampf an
und landtagswahlkampf bei dem ich um die
stimmen von zig millionen menschen
werben kann ich den komplett
digitalisiert und das ist die frage die
ich mir stelle die ich stell mir noch
eine andere frage ab ob man das haben
wir fast ein jahr pandemie gelernt auch
den umgang wir haben ganz viel darüber
gelernt
wären wir auch nicht bereit viel
eigenverantwortlicher mit dieser
pandemie umzugehen selber zu entscheiden
gerade wenn ich jetzt schnell test hätte
private schnelltest sich selber machen
kann selber zu schauen dass ich mich so
zu verhalten dass ich mich schütze das
ich entscheiden kann in welches geschäft
ich gehe mit wieviel leute nicht da sein
muss werden es wäre das nicht jetzt auch
an der zeit
also wir haben dazu mal die antwort der
bevölkerung in der ersten welle
angeschaut
wir haben gesehen dass schon lange vor
maßnahmen in der ersten welle die
menschen vorsichtig geworden sind ist
völlig freiwillig zu hause geblieben und
das foto dann durch maßnahmen verstärkt
aber wir haben das haben diese signale
gesehen sind diese positive richtung des
menschen vorsichtig werden wenn sie die
pandemie gekommen die man dann
vorsichtig ähnliches verhalten auch bei
als diese neue variante sich ausbreitet
aber diese diese effekte werden
natürlich immer schwächer weil die leute
halt müde werden pandemie denn das ist
eine unfassbare stresssituation und
deshalb bin ich auch immer sehr
vorsichtig das heißt wenn wenn
wir nicht zum beispiel durch testen
begleitete schuleröffnung machen also
tests sind ungeheuer das zeigen alle
studien sehr effektiv also natürlich
nicht die krankheit zu bekämpfen aber
leute zu identifizieren die dann positiv
sind die dann garantiert werden alle
studien zeigen dass das man auch
sporadisches testen das sehr effektiv
ist was man unbedingt vermeiden muss ist
das nach vier wochen das dann wieder
durch die decke geht ich glaube das hält
keiner mehr aus also lieber in länger
dann doch noch ja hin zurück und auch
differenziert also immer wir gucken sie
uns die deutschlandcard es gibt
landkreise die haben darunter zwanziger
incidents da müssen da kann man ganz
anders agieren also diese idee an der
gaststätte aufmachen würde würden die
aus den anderen landkreisen dahin kommen
dass das ein eben genau nicht so also
genau das sind immer so karikatur
wahrnehmung der realität zwar 80 prozent
der mobilität zum beispiel findet
innerhalb von landkreisen das
allermeiste noch mal 80 prozent davon
sind einfach berufspendler es passiert
nur ganz wenig dass dieses diese diese
bilder von diesen worden die dann über
die landkreisgrenze in irgendwelche
cafés stürmen das gibt s oder das ist
eine total verzerrte wahrnehmung und
soul eine differenziertere 80 maßnahmen
schnell bei niedrigen zahlen und sehr
spezifisch reagieren also ein landkreis
mit einem zehner intelligenz ist was
anderes als 150 ist was ganz anderes ja
frau glas eben noch die frage nach
israel wir schauen immer noch die
impfung aber ich würde gerne mal wissen
wie vor hat das da wie funktioniert das
mit dem schnelltest ist das was was
schon so ganz normal auch ist in den
letzten wochen dass man sich überall
testet also schnelltests zu hause er
nicht das wird jetzt erst diskutiert
aber es gibt überall testzentren wo sie
hingehen können in tel aviv das wird
dann zum teil vom militär oder auch von
sanitätern organisiert da gibt es laute
discomusik wenn sie reingehen
relativ schnell getestet bekommen dann
das ergebnis aufs handy aber
nichtsdestotrotz könnte an der ganzen
diskussion ja kostenlos oder weil das
ist ja auch noch eine frage ja viel darf
es kostenlos kost kostenlos kostenlos
die impfungen sind auch kostenlos und
zum beispiel ich habe ja auch keine
krankenkasse in israel habe eine
krankenkasse in deutschland und trotzdem
ich wurde hier auch kostenlos dann
geimpft getestet also wer da kommt das
betrifft dann zum beispiel auch
asylsuchende oder philippinische
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter also da wird
hier keine unterscheidung gemacht
sondern man kann sich hier tolles
kostenlos testen und impfen lassen aber
bei der ganzen diskussion die sie jetzt
auch hier führen denke ich mir wenn
israel diese raschen impfungen nicht
gehabt hätte dann wird es ja auch ganz
anders aussehen weil man merkt einfach
man kann die leute speziell
wahrscheinlich auch mit der mentalität
er hier im raum nicht lange wegsperren
oder ihnen etwas verbieten also zum
beispiel nicht erlaubt war dass die
restaurants bedienen hieß es wir machen
home delivery und dann hat man auf der
anderen straßenseite die tische
aufgestellt und dann sehen die menschen
einfach auf die andere straßenseite
gegangen und der kellner hat home der
liebe zu dem tisch auf der anderen
straßenseite gemacht also da als
ziemliche auswüchse gehabt und auch die
kommunikation der israelischen regierung
die wir zum teil eher chaotisch man hat
an einem tag erklärt man schließlich
stehen die am nächsten tag auf druck der
großen lobby das dann doch wieder nicht
gemacht also ohne die impfungen würde es
bei uns hier auch vollkommen anders
aussehen ich denke man muss irgendwann
mal akzeptieren die leute wollen wieder
ein stück normalität und man muss dann
auch etwas auf eigenverantwortung hoffen
aber muss tempo machen bei den test bei
den impfungen heraus wenn man jetzt der
herr brandner den wahlkampf schon
angesprochen was wird das einen wird
diese wahl durch corona bestimmt werden
und ist es kommt es jetzt auf diese
nächsten wochen an werde am besten auch
weg in welchem land wie sich am besten
verhält
auf ganz vielen ebenen wird krone dieses
war ja dominieren als thema wir werden
ganz ganz viel über dieses thema
sprechen
vor allem auch über das management der
pandemie und das auch völlig legitim
dass darüber gestritten wird
aber es wird auch die format natürlich
berühren herr prantl hat es ja
angesprochen tür zu tür wahlkampf mag
sogar gehen im sommer das ist ja doch
noch mal eine andere situation dann aber
großveranstaltung wird es sicherlich
keine geben und bis hin zur art der
stimmabgabe wird eine rolle spielen wir
werden vielmehr briefwahl haben wir
finden ob oder die wahlleiter finden
kaum freiwillige die im wahllokal sitzen
weil sie befürchtungen haben dass sie
sich anstecken also auf der ebene
berührt corona ganz fundamental
dieses war ja zu hoffen bleibt wirklich
und das ist aus demokratie theoretischer
sicht entscheidende punkt dass wir
wirklich debatten führen es wäre
eigentlich aus systemischer sicht das
schlimmste wenn wir einfach eine nicht
wahlkampf führen würden
dafür ist die situation viel zu
gravieren dafür steht viel zu viel auf
dem spiel
was will ich auf die andere seite ganz
wichtig dass man das gefühl hat die
regierung sieht er an einem strang
natürlich den spd-fraktionschef mütze
nicht der ja das ist ein ganz schmaler
grat gern ersparen er ist ein
ankündigungsminister das ist ja ein ton
der gab der folge ja genau so wie sie es
formulieren das ist glaube ich der
schmale grat es darf nicht der eindruck
entstehen dass es eine eine symbolische
auseinandersetzung ist bei der es nicht
um die sache geht dass es darum geht
vermeintlich billige punkte billige
treffer zu landen das geht auch in nicht
pandemie zeiten übrigens menschen haben
ein sehr feines sensorium dafür ob er
ernsthaft debattiert wird oder ob das
eigentliche show debatten sind bei denen
es eigentlich nicht um die sache geht
und sicherlich droht ein wenig dass so
viel angriffsfläche hierdurch die korona
entstanden ist dass man dazu geneigt ist
schnell mal so ein treffer zu landen
aber eigentlich geht es um ganz ganz
andere frage man kann über so viele
fragen aus anlass der pandemie
diskutieren digitalisierung bildung
ungleich längere lebens bereiten sich
die hoffnung der brand lief formuliert
hätte handel würden sie sagen das ist
gerade eine besondere chance für die
demokratie also diese krise auch in
einem bar jetzt auch noch oder ist es
eine besondere gefahr
und ja es wird ja immer davon geredet
dass die krise in der krise eine große
chance steckt ich würde mir erhoffen
dass endlich der bundesrat die chance
ergreifen bundestag
ist eigentlich in einem ganzen jahr
komplett ausgefallen der bundestag muss
seine rolle als souverän wahrnehmen der
bundestag muss viel intensiver
debattieren ist die debatten an weniger
in der regierungsstadt zu finden die
debatten haben im parlament statt zu
finden und wenn sie im parlament
stattfinden
dann sind sie in kristall als
kristallisationspunkt für die
öffentliche debatte
dann läuft die öffentliche debatte
völlig anders dann ist die krone politik
transparenter ich denke wir stehen
tatsächlich vorentscheidenden monaten
und die leute sind nicht ganz blöd
nachdem die zahlen für sie da
beispielsweise am anfang ungeheuer groß
waren hat man glaube ich gemerkt dass
die ausweise wie markus söder corona
politik treibt sehr auf showeffekte
ausgelegt ist das ja immer diejenige war
von dem man das gefühl hatte kaum hat
die ministerpräsidenten runde getagt
überlegt sich die söhne runde zu hause
in der staatskanzlei
was könnten wir jetzt schon wieder aus
hecken an einer forderung nach einer
impfpflicht um vielleicht doch mehr
schlagzeilen zu haben als sie herr
laschet hat das ist eine art von politik
digital.de auf den geist und auf die
autopreise glaube ich wird man nicht
kanzlerkandidat das ist das erste was
ich feststellen möchte wenn hier eine
sensibilität herrscht wie wirklich gute
corona politik ausschaut
dann wäre ich ganz zufrieden und dann
wäre mein konzept wenn sie mich fragen
wie soll ich für die nächsten monate aus
schauen dann sage ich mehr testen mehr
impfen und mehr private verantwortung
weil die art und weise wie die
bürgerinnen und bürger in den letzten
monaten behandelt worden sind mit
kontaktsperre und sie dürfen sich nur
mit einem menschen außerhalb des eigenen
haushalts dreßen die waren lächerlich
und kinder schon da wurden die grenzen
des rechtlich regelbaren wirklich um
lichtjahre überschritten china braucht
man was werden nächste woche gibt's ja
wieder der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
was würden sie sich da wünschen sagen
sie hat den fall strenger und bleiben
oder gibt es noch würden sie dann ein
bisschen das ganze eröffnet also also
ich glaube es gibt strategien und wege
der lockerung begleitet durch testen und
impfen also
gibt ihn tatsächlich intelligente lösung
die erarbeitet worden sind zum beispiel
von der no credit gruppe ja da kann man
halt sehen wie das ist ja das sind ja
strategien zur öffnung zur lockerung
also für das laden geben dass man würde
den machen genau stufen also dass man
dass man regionaler lokaler agieren kann
instituts abhängig dass wir und dass man
schneller reagiert wenn das man nicht
erst drei wochen debattiert ob jetzt
eine dritte welle kommt oder nicht
sondern das man halt sofort reagiert in
diesen niedrig hin zu dance dass man
auch neue technologien verwenden also da
ist noch stück arbeit und das schaffen
wir jetzt auch nicht mehr in dieser
runde zu besprechen vielen dank herr
prantl frau glas nutella wie für
brockmann
herr fast das war die phoenix runde
heute ab montag dürfen sie auf jeden
fall schon mal zum friseur das hilft
dann auch
ich wollte ihnen noch sagen dass die
phoenix runde ob jetzt auch bei spotify
als podcast gibt also können sie uns
auch hören obwohl es auch schön ist wenn
sie uns sehen und morgen liebe zuschauer
innen reden wir übers ländern in der
sprache und ich freue mich wenn sie
dabei sind bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]